at one point my life
for years I hadn't spoken to anyone or
sent in emails and I remember the day I
came back had all my luggage with me and
I just I knocked at the door she opened
it she said hi she smiled and she she
just asked me what I wanted for dinner
and you know she didn't ask me any
questions she just let me come in with
everything I had and it's I guess his
unconditional love no questions I asked
no wise and nothing she's a success me
you know she wakes up early in the
morning does 10 to 12 hour shifts comes
home late at night cooks us food smiles
and and goes to bed and rinse and repeat
and all this to to provide for us you
know so I know what the burden she has I
have a tremendous amount of fiber so you
ask me who my mother is she's definitely
the strongest person I know
well he's a large amount of her stress
comes from her house she bought that
house for us for the kids so that we
would have a home to come to forever and
you know over the years how she's
getting older she she's having a hard
time keeping up with the bills so I've
been saving for the last few years I've
been getting ready it's uh today's my
birthday yeah I forgot to mention that
so I kind of wanted to do something for
her yeah
oh wow
Wow
Wow very super Buddha send us just about
what which are yeah
[Music]
and what are you doing right you
my life has always been about giving
back so I want to do something special
for her now you know I want to just want
to celebrate my life by celebrating the
woman
I think that's a good answer
[Music]